it's amazing though and you know again i
think it's just like a reminder that you
know the event that happened on sunday
uh
just the power of professional sports or
live events of sports and then
again to me just the fact that you know
here's two legends it shows you the
power of manning and brady still and it
shows you the power of football a little
bit that people want to see these two
you know ones that has been the other
ones at the end of his career and they
people still want to tune in watch these
guys go at it and i get it and right now
i especially get it because we're all
starved for a little competition there's
no doubt about that
yeah it was raining pretty much the
entire time but when you put peyton
manning with tiger woods and tom brady
with phil mickelson they did the match
they raised millions for the all in
challenging covet 19 relief and you know
some of the things that they did during
the broadcast it was the highest rated
cable broadcast ever for a golf match
but put put microphones on the golfers
what the hell i i want to hear those
guys while they're talking to each other
out there on the course in a competitive
environment it makes it a hell of a lot
more compelling
it definitely does i mean not i'm not
going to sit here and lie i didn't watch
a lot of this all right i mean i kind of
just was i was at my parents house
i was kind of tuning in tuning out
seeing this here and there but it
certainly sounded like there was good
banter and anybody anytime you can like
kind of get behind the curtain or behind
the scenes with hearing professional
athletes talk and what's their approach
and their mentality it is always cool i
mean even for a guy like me who's been
around it my whole life and and of
course played at one point you know i
enjoyed watching brady talk crap to
barkley and barkley talk crap to brady i
mean that was cool that was part of what
you tuned in to see
and good banter can offset bad golf and
we saw notwithstanding the shot at the
top of the show plenty of bad golf from
hashtag tommy and and you know it it's
it's refreshing to see and do you re if
you're a buccaneers fan do you want your
quarterback to be great at golf no you
want to be great at football look that's
we can all relate to these shots this is
normal this is human he is not a robot
one there hey you know this is good we
like it and and and here's the thing
chris
for all of the crap golf that we saw
from tom brady it was this shot at the
top that will get him to keep golfing
that is the truth that applies to anyone
who has ever golfed there is always one
shot per round that makes you think
you're better than you are that is the
magnet that brings you back for more
golf and you eventually forget about all
the times you were gonna smash your
clubs into a tree and you remember that
one shot so for all the other stuff it's
the one shot with the pants split at the
end that that will get tom brady back on
a course well yeah you know
to your point though it does humanize
him and i think that's the part that you
know it was like kind of refreshing to
see here's this guy that's got the
perfect life and he's amazing and he's
the goat and all those things right to
see him you know go through some of the
struggles that all people go through
playing golf or have a pair of pants
that split that happens to all people at
times uh it was cool and it was just
good it was a good event regardless it
was great for a great cause i enjoyed
watching you know bits and pieces of it
again i wasn't gonna sit there and watch
it for five straight hours my dad was
very much into it but uh either way it
looked cool and uh it's always good to
see legends go at it and you look like
talk about legends oh man do you look
good today with that haircut oh baby you
look happy
it's grown out it's grown out four days
it's a little bit longer than it was on
friday hey um here's the thing and and i
i'm not one to question
tv programming decisions but there's a
reason why the nfl doesn't start its
season anymore on labor day weekend
people don't want to sit inside and
watch football they want to be out doing
things on labor day weekend i question
the wisdom of having this thing on the
sunday of memorial day weekend because
people wanted to be outside it was
beautiful i'm with you
i'm picking up what i picked up from
highlights and social media and whatnot
i turned it on at 3 p.m and it was
driving rainstorm and i waited for the
thing to start and the thing never
started it was like i got to get outside
it's too nice i got people coming over
you know we had a very careful
socially distant gathering on sunday but
we have enough area where we can get
some family members there and make some
steaks and had a normal day or at least
something that felt as close to normal
as anything has since
i don't know
the the end of the year holidays and uh
so i'm not gonna hang around and i know
you can watch it on your phone and
whatnot but it's you get to a point
where it's like all right it i
this isn't a day for watching tv this is
a day for being outside and that's why i
think it's a weird weekend to do
something like that even though well
even though many disagreed with this
chris again it was no doubt people who
watch the thing
well yeah i mean i mean no doubt i mean
i'm with you though mike you know first
off yeah my my sister had a new baby so
my new nephew is there but yeah the kids
want to be outside we haven't had warm
weather here in the northeast so i was
outside and hey as much as i love tiger
woods and lefty and peyton manning and
tom brady i mean again
it's not like it was the masters or the
u.s open all right i mean all you had to
do is like you said watch a few shots
and you went whoa okay i've been
watching for 10 minutes and i you know
between peyton manning and tom brady
i've seen a lot of crappy shots and the
other two you know they're past their
prime too in golf so i i wasn't going to
sit there and tune in like this was
can't miss sports i just i it didn't
appeal to me that way i'm sorry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports